[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, so the
idea is to believe
in a more brilliant world.
Of course, this requires a
childlike state of wonder.
As Alan Harrington wrote
in The Immortalist,
we must all remain
uncompromising child voyagers--
retain a child's eye
view of what might be.
What happens with
adults is that we
become jaded-- the
been theres and done
thats of the adult mind.
It's a form of laziness.
It's a form of dispensing
with the here and now
and jumping to the conclusions.
It's a sort of impatience
with lived life
that we need to transcend.
We need to re-engage
with the senses.
We need awaken the
mind's attention
from the lethargy of custom
and the film of familiarity,
and redirecting it instead
to the wonders of existence.
Absolute unmixed attention
is a form of prayer.
Looking begins with love.
Love begins with looking.
This is the eye of the child.
This is the mind of the child.
We're all born artists.
We're all born ecstasy seekers.
And then it just gets
pummeled out of us.
It gets stripped
away by banality.
What is banality and boredom, if
not defences the educated mind,
employs against experience
so that it's not continually
exhaustingly astonished,
as Michael Pollan wrote
in The Botany of Desire?
And it's true, it would be
astonishing to be open to it
all at any given time.
Just read James Joyce.
But we must, nonetheless,
strive to reenter these spaces,
because these are the
only spaces that have ever
led to visions that have
transformed the world.
That, my friends, is that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]